au lit il y a pas besoin à Genève tout
le monde des milliardaires
dans le coin de cette rue si tu peux
filmer
à chaque fois qu'on passe dans une ville
on laisse un album let's go allez pas
trop loin
désolé si vous le trouvez
mentionnez-nous
direction Annecy let's rocking
[Rires]
bonjour à tous je sais que vous vous
demandez qui coiffe les artistes avant
les télés avant les spectacles et ben
moi je vous présente mon coiffeur
d'avance spectacle
et aussi du dimanche il a quel âge vous
avez monsieur
six ans et demi et il me fait des
sublimes coiffures et vous qui fait vos
coiffures du dimanche
je vais être belle
[Musique]
et bonjour à tous on est à allô comme
vous pouvez le voir je sais pas si vous
voyez le clocher oui vous voyez le
clocher de l'eau là et je suis avec
comment tu t'appelles mon nom
à l'école et tout et ben oui obligatoire
salut tout le monde j'espère que vous
allez bien je profite de ce petit moment
parce qu'en ce moment c'est promo promo
promo pour le pour le nouvel album comme
vous vous pouvez vous imaginer mais je
voulais profiter de ce moment pour vous
annoncer bientôt une surprise donc
restez connectés ça arrive à grands pas
et ces questions de se mettre dans
l'ambiance de la tournée si vous voyez
ce que je veux dire allez salut à très
vite